One of the most overrated lightweights to
take a term from Trump's vocabulary is former
South Carolina governor and former Trump ambassador
to the United Nations, Nikki Haley.
Nikki Haley wasted no time in appearing on
Farcical Newsmax, hosted by by Sean Spicer.
Yeah, that Sean Spicer, Trump's pathetic former
press secretary, Sean Spicer.
And she went on to talk to Sean Spicer on
Newsmax, rehabilitating the same tired, predictable
talking points that I've been telling you
for a year now would instantly reappear when
a Democrat is sworn into office and Donald
Trump leaves.
Now, a year ago, we didn't even know which
Democrat it might be that replaces Donald
Trump, but it didn't matter.
No matter which Democrat replace Trump, they
would go all debt and deficit.
We can't afford this.
We can't afford that.
The far left socialists are taking over.
We knew what the playbook was going to be.
And here is Nikki Haley playing her role,
saying that Joe Biden's far left foreign policy
is going to be very dangerous.
Listen to her answer after Sean Spicer manages
to cough out this softball question.
You have this new op ed out that you talk
about the Democrats going leftward.
But I want to talk about this in the context
of Biden and his foreign policy, specifically
who he's appointed and who and the policies
that he's going to pursue.
Can you kind of talk about where you think
the Biden foreign policy and the Biden personnel
picks are going to go direction wise?
I mean, look, I'm not going to lie.
I'm extremely concerned about what's going
on.
You've got Iran.
They're in the process of producing nuclear
weapons.
And here Biden wants to get back into the
Iran deal.
She's very concerned by notice the idiocy
of what she says.
She says, look, Iran is producing nuclear
weapons and Biden wants back into the deal.
Don't let them trick you.
OK, first of all, Iran is resuming resuming
research into nuclear.
They're not producing weapons yet, but they
could.
But what she's saying is not true.
But, yes, Iran is resuming research.
Why is Iran resuming research into nuclear
power and nuclear energy, which could be used
for weapons?
Iran is doing that because they abided by
the nuclear deal that Barack Obama struck
with them.
Trump came into office and simply canceled
it without Iran having done anything wrong.
So, of course, as I told you the day Trump
did this, that Iran was going to go back to
nuclear research and they did the Iran deal
was the only thing keeping Iran from doing
the nuclear research.
And now Nikki Haley is already blaming Biden
for wanting to get back into the deal, which
was actually working to stop Iran from developing.
Is this bad faith or is Nikki that ignorant?
I have a really hard time believing that Nikki
Haley is this ignorant.
I assume that this is just bad faith pandering
to a radical Newsmax audience that doesn't
know any better.
Let's listen to a little bit more of this.
When you look at his picks for cabinet and
otherwise, I mean, from John Kerry to Susan
Rice, you don't have to be that much of a
historian to know where this is going.
And I think this is going to be to the left
of Obama.
I think we need to hold on to our wallet.
And I think we need to stop with all of the
the finger pointing and the he said she said
and we've got to get to work.
This is this is going to hurt.
And we need to really be focused on where
we're going to go from here.
Isn't that just outrageous and pathetic?
John Kerry and Susan Rice, completely uncontroversial,
milquetoast, moderate Democrats, nothing radical
about John Kerry and Susan Rice, nothing socialist
about them.
John Kerry, very smart, more than well qualified,
understands climate issues.
These are the far left scary people.
Now, John Kerry is far left now.
And then, of course, she says we've got to
hold on to our wallets.
What you might be wondering, what is she talking
about? Trump exploded the deficit more than
any recent president, more than Obama, more
than Bush.
Clinton had a surplus, never mind.
What is she talking about?
The stimulus and infrastructure spending that
Biden wants is much needed it.
Generates revenue by creating jobs and putting
money back into the hands of small businesses.
So I hate that I'm right about this.
I hate that I was right.
And many of you were as well.
You e-mailed me and said, David, they're going
back to the debt and deficit and all of the
stuff.
They aren't even waiting for Joe Biden to
be sworn in to get back to the pathetic talking
points that we had a four year break from.
The question is, are the same right wingers
going to fall for the same talking points
again or has the ship sailed?
Remains to be seen, but there is going to
be plenty of this on Fox News on on and on
Newsmax.
And it is going to take everything.
We have to take a group that has already there
already so in need of deprogramming and now
you're going to see Newsmax and 081 scale
up and maybe you'll see Fox News do it as
well to try to keep up with them.
It's going to be a very much uphill battle
and they are wasting no time The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman Dotcom.